hello and welcome to playstation grenade
apex legend is a great take on battle
royale but it's so new we're all still
learning everything about the game
i've been stalking the developers on
twitter and those streaming masters over
on twitch and have compiled 100 pro tips
there's loads i've probably missed here
so if you have a tip write it below
i'll give it a heart to get you noticed
anyway you ready let's do this
[Music]
when dropping from the ship keep one eye
on your velocity meter when gliding with
a horizontal torso you will gradually
lose speed be sure to dive down
regularly to regain that momentum to
reach your target quicker
if you're a passive player and you
prefer to drop further away from other
teams
use this method of diving to get there
quicker dive to gain momentum
level out dive to give momentum level
out always keep an eye on that glider
speed
when a new game begins look at the small
print on the map the blue circle is a
hot drop area meaning there's going to
be a few teams here
trying to take this point it has the
highest chances of top
tier loot on the entire map including a
fully kitted weapon
to make your squad gods if you're
aggressive but don't fancy the unknowing
hot drop area
try use the drop ship which moves around
from the start of the game
landing here usually rewards you with
quality weapons but it's more than
likely you'll not be the only ones here
it's important to stay with your group
in apex legends when following your drop
master try to break away at the last
moment to stay close
but not so close that you're taking
weapons away from each other so we're on
the ground now and from our experience
bullets can be hard to come by in early
game
this is where communication is vital
bring up your inventory and use the
freaking awesome ping system
to tell your teammates what you need on
console that's the r1 button
whilst in your inventory look at the
bullet icon next to the weapon you have
it's a godsend ping this to let your
buddies know what you need
if your team wants to win they'll split
ammo to help you out you can ping
anything inside this inventory screen if
you need help finding an extended mac
ping the slots on the flip side of that
ping things you don't pick up
helmets armor backpacks high level
attachments body shield here
level two if you're playing with randoms
without a mic you're going to need all
help you can get
this system is that help carrying on
from this always have in the back of
your mind the weapon you are trying to
find
maybe you love the wingman maybe you
prefer the hemlock try to be proactive
and find the ammo for that weapon
and a few attachments for the moment you
finally stumble across your bay
then you're instantly ready for battle
oh and a quick reminder if you see the
apex crate bot in the world smash it for
additional loot
[Music]
damage numbers are colour-coded to armor
quality
white indicates a standard common shield
meaning that guy
has a maximum health of 150 the blue
number indicates a rare shield meaning
they could have 175 health in total
and the purple indicates potentially 200
hit points
if you see yellow numbers you hit them
in the head and finally if the numbers
are red
red indicates that they have no shield
so they only have a maximum of 100
health oh and if you hear that smashing
sound that's their shield giving up this
should be your team's moment
to rush in and finish the fight a
general piece of advice from many pro
players is to switch the damage numbers
in settings
to floating as it will show your damage
after each hit rather than
accumulative in total if you've played
fortnite this will feel more like home
remember to put your weapons away out of
battle you'll move much faster hold
triangle on ps4 to do that
and is it just me is gibraltar running
slower than everyone else well we tested
it he's not all the characters run at
the same speed
the difference is the slower hand
animation playing mind tricks on us
similarly wraith is not moving any
faster even with that ridiculous anime
run enabled
you can gain a small speed boost by
first running then going into a slide
and then jumping out of that animation
it's only a small amount but it makes a
huge difference on
long jogs through the storm not only is
this slightly quicker it also makes you
harder to hit predicting somebody
bobbing and weaving is very difficult
just
ask a boxer so don't give your enemy an
easy shot even when stuck in the open
still talking about traversal when going
downhill be sure to slide for yet
another speed boost
coincidentally you can use medical items
while sliding
bloody useful yet again we all know that
high ground can be a game changer in
fights with
pathfinder's grappling hook a great way
to quickly get above foes
did you know that you can use doors to
double vault to high ground
an open door can be hurdled upon so even
my thick boy gibraltar can take the high
ground
if you find a group holed up in a
building use grenades to blow the door
open rainbow six siege style throw a
second one in and watch them abandon
that building
in general don't dismiss your nades
always take a few they can be thrown
crazy far
if you have the high ground throw them
down on other teams there's a short fuse
time it's a few seconds so it should
perfectly coincide when you throw it off
a cliff
going back to doors for a second it's
possible to block them with your body
as ah on the other hand you can break
through these with melee
if you do this the rule is straight you
must shout out this anna schwarzenegger
quote
when looting corpses pay attention to
the strike icon this little blighter
helps you quickly realize you do not
require this item breeze past it so you
can loot quicker i play with a chat
called zach who steals loot from
everyone's kills
so we all must learn to loot faster and
also exact sucks
when switching guns the game will
automatically move across any attachment
to a new weapon
of course this will only work if they
fit oh remember the ping system
it works when looting two ping things
inside these dashes for your teammates
we all need to be better teammates if
you're killed in battle
don't leave your carcass has a chip
which can be picked up by your teammates
taking this chip to a respawn beacon
will get you back in the fight
the problem is you'll be completely
naked you'll have nothing no armor no
weapon
it also doesn't matter who picked up
your tag anyone in your squad
can call the respawn by the way a great
teammate will drop a gun for their
friends
or maybe tag one nearby on the flip side
of that if you hear a respawn station
used get over there you know you're only
facing two fully equipped enemies at the
most because usually the third is easy
pickings
and in case you didn't know enemy
caskets are colour-coded gold means you
may find a top-tier weapon here
but more likely it's just an attachment
then you're already aware
next is purple then blue and then good
old grey when escaping the storm or
rotating to a new position
look at the skyline spotting a
redeployed balloon early can save you a
great deal of time
when using it don't jump off too early
your character can only use their
redeploy glider if they get all the way
to the top
another great way to use these redeploy
points is to take advantage of going out
of bounds
when out of bounds you've got 30 seconds
to get back in the fight that's bloody
ages
run across the mountaintops to flank
enemies make sure you beat the clock
though or you'll forever be sat on top
of that mountain
oh and if you are not do you know that
you can open and close doors to
frustrate enemies and protect a friend
while they are being raised when knocked
you are still able to ping enemy
locations so be sure to do so especially
if you aren't in chat
saying that always call out when an
opponent is rezzing
this second can give you an easy victory
and stop a two-on-one in the latter
stages
you can also use your knocked body to
block off enemies and make eye lines
difficult
if you have a shield one down you can
downright piss them off before you die
so i guess what i'm saying is use down
teammates as cover
cannon fodder there's a small chance
you'll find gold items in the game the
weapons like the mastiff shotgun and the
cable sniper
are easily the best in the game but the
other golden items
although very rare have a secret benefit
a passive skill
let's look at them the digital threat
scope attachment will highlight enemies
in red
the golden knockout shield will grant
you the ability to self-revive when
knocked
this completely befuddles the enemy when
you rise from the ashes
like phoenix the golden backpack allows
you to use health
and shield consumables in half the time
it would take anyone else
the golden armor will reward those
execution kills those cinematic kills
with full shield instant 100 shield of
course it can be risky though finishing
someone as you're open to bullets the
whole time
and finally the helmet which will make
your active abilities regen faster
allowing for more ultimates in a game oh
and the best place to find gold tier
items
is via airdrops speaking of helmets
helmets don't award shields instead they
reduce headshot damage
a white helm will reduce headshot damage
by 30 blue 40
and purple and gold will half all damage
to your brain box
50 less and the key point to know here
helmets cannot break
they don't need to be restored once
you're wearing it it's permanent
lots of people are transitioning from
fortnite to apex or trying to play both
at the same time
so let's quickly go through a few things
you should be aware of we're still
waiting for this to be confirmed by the
developers but it appears
bigger characters have bigger hitboxes
in apex legends
test it for yourself though compare
shooting thick boy gibraltar
against the little tiny emo wraith i
know which one i find easier to hit
apex legend uses projectile damage which
means the bullet has to physically
travel over to the enemy
unlike the majority of weapons in
fortnite which are hitscan
meaning if your reticle is over the
target the instance that you shoot
it's already reached the target to be
better at apex you'll need to slightly
adjust your aim slightly in front
slightly above
you'll get it as you go along aim assist
is almost non-existent in apex legends
many controller players are struggling
here at first
because of the help we received in
fortnite aim assist is definitely still
here
but i'll let you learn how to abuse it
in many games gun recoil is randomized
to make weapons rightly feel out of
control when firing
while in apex all weapons have a
consistent recoil pattern
learn the way your favorite weapon fires
and you'll be able to counter it
controlling the recoil
apex uses scale damage we all know how
headshots are the quickest way to down
an opponent but did you know that
shooting someone in the foot
does less damage than their torso so if
you're like me and can't hit head shots
make sure you at least hit the chest
lifeline has a great ultimate she calls
in supply drops
this can actually be great for other
teams to ambush all in-game supply drops
are shown on the map so if you see one
coming in
check your map and you'll instantly know
if it's your salute
of yours to ambush oh here's a cool one
about scaling a wall
if you release the jump just before the
end of the animation it allows you to
hold on to the top of the wall
and check your surroundings before
committing to climbing up
let's move on to certain character tips
did you know the void riffs that wraith
leaves behind can be traveled through
even when you're downed
pretty cool when playing as gibraltar
use your bubble shield to dictate battle
standing inside at the edge
hop in hop out to take a few shots and
keep in mind that he has a passive
shield which doubles
for extra cover coincidentally if you
played halo an old strat can be used
against the shield
run in drop a nade run out again this
will force the opposition to leave the
bubble
or face the consequences mirage's decoy
ability can be used whilst gliding
use it to trick the opposition on where
you're landing when playing as
bloodhound your tracking skills are
increased
when using a long range sniper earlier
we talked about blocking doors with your
body did you know that cost it can block
doors with his canisters
blocking them in to take full damage
this is the reason why we have melee to
smash doors
a few general tips to end if you have ps
plus check out the freebies in the store
regularly skins and cosmetics will be
added like this sexy bastard
i know this is said too much but in
battle royale games take as many
gunfights as you can to improve
the revive system is so substantial that
even a noob like me can benefit from
fights
i don't mean going alone it's a squad
game for a reason and you know what i've
just broken my final tip
play however the heck you want don't let
anyone say you're doing it wrong
but for the love of god please play as a
team as that's how it's intended
to be played i'm adam from playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure
if you want to talk to me come and grab
me on twitter i'm always around
and remember to put a comment below if
you have a tip you want to share with
other people
right i'm going i'll see you next time
or if not i'll see you on the
battlefield i'm the fat lad who dies
first all the time see you next time